[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigeren löhnen freitagabend ihnen
allen christian autos wieder bei mir für
den sport sehr gern genannt und
gemeinsam blicken wir jetzt auf unseren
themen überblick
empörung nach raketenangriff auf kiew
den russischen beschuss während des
besuchs von un-chef guten schnitt berlin
menschenverachtend
kritik an kürzerer isolations zeit für
corona infizierte die geplante fünf tage
frist stößt auf widerstand
patientenschützer fordern eine frei
testung pflicht
und tiefer fall einer tennis ikone boris
becker muss ins gefängnis ein londoner
gericht verurteilt ihn wegen
insolvenzverschleppung zu zweieinhalb
jahren haft
[Musik]
ukraine präsident selensky hat sich bei
den usa für die geplanten militär und
wirtschaftshilfen in höhe von 33
milliarden dollar bedankt und den
russischen raketenangriff auf kiew
während des besuches des
un-generalsekretärs gestern scharf
verurteilt ebenso die bundesregierung an
den kriegsfronten im osten und süden
wird weiter hart und erbittert gekämpft
die geschehnisse am kriegstag 65 fasst
jürgen kehl zusammen
kiew am mittag in dieses appartement
haus war eine der raketen eingeschlagen
in den trümmern finden die retter eine
tote frau eine unserer journalistinnen
sagt radio free europe ein
amerikanischer sender das russische
verteidigungsministerium erklärt man
habe in kiew nur militärische ziele
zerstört bewohner berichten von fünf
einschlägen
es ist so schwer die töten so viele
menschen die lassen niemanden leben
zurück entschuldigung ich kann nicht
mehr
politisch brisant zum zeitpunkt der
attacke der ersten seit knapp zwei
wochen war der oberste uno repräsentant
zu gesprächen mit der ukrainischen
regierung in der stadt
hierfür ist heilig für ukraine und
russen es ist nicht wichtig ob der
un-generalsekretär hier ist oder nicht
das ist eine so schöne stadt die so
wichtig ist für die geschichte und die
kultur dass die angegriffen wird das
schockiert mich natürlich
das ist ein symbolischer moment der
un-generalsekretär ist in kiew mit der
zerstörung unserer häuser mit den
beschuss zeigt den putin genau dann den
mittelfinger
dione und die ganze welt blicken seit
wochen auf das stahlwerk in mariupol
noch immer verschanzen sich dort
ukrainische kämpfen zahlreiche
zivilisten
aufnahmen des chinesischen fernsehens
zeigen an den konvoi der sich
möglicherweise für eine evakuierung
bereit hält in der nieder gewalzten
stadt sind nur noch wenige bewohner
geblieben zeugen und fassbarer gewalt
das ist wie das ende der welt sagt diese
frau so ähnlich ist das hier sie
berichtet von hunger schreienden kindern
und raketenwerfern direkt hinter ihrem
haus
russland zeigt heute panzer und
artillerie im angriff die feindliche
logistik sei weiter eines der
bevorzugten ziele heißt es auch die
ukraine meldet erfolge ein
munitionslager auf russisch
kontrolliertem gebiet soll zerstört
worden sein von einer komplexen lage
sprach der uno-generalsekretär bei
seinem abschied heißt im klartext die
gewalt wird weitergehen
vom osten her schiebt sich die
frontlinie langsam ins land und immer
mehr menschen müssen damit rechnen unter
beschuss zu geraten auch in popows einer
bergbau und industrie statt mit früher
einmal 65.000 einwohnern von dort
berichtet unser reporter dara
hassanzadeh
prof die letzte stadt vor der front noch
sind die kriegsschäden hier
vergleichsweise gering wir treffen
nicolai er ist für die sicherheit in der
stadt fahren freundlich
bei luftangriffen einschlägen von
mörsern oder explosionen schicken wir
die leute in die keller die wir
vorbereitet haben
keller werden zu bunkern vorräte an
essen und medikamenten für die menschen
sind angelegt selbst brunnen für wasser
haben sie gebohrt
die menschen hier leben mit der hoffnung
dass der krieg ihre stadt verschonen
wird sie leben mit der angst dass die
russische armee die letzten wenigen
kilometer erobern wird dass sie
eingekesselt werden und ihre stadt
zerstört wird essensausgabe ohne hilfe
würden die menschen hier hungern eine
tüte sie muss für zwei tage reichen
wir kaufen nur brot selbst im moment
gibt es kaum zucker auch kein mehl den
rest tauschen wir untereinander
nur wer bei der stadt angestellt ist
verdient noch geld alle anderen müssen
versorgt werden
wir beamte können jetzt nicht gehen es
ist unmöglich wie würden wir uns dann
fühlen wie ein verräter nein das ist
nicht unser welt
noch 20.000 menschen leben in prof und
sie wissen am horizont dort ist der
krieg
moskaus drohungen haben in den
vergangenen tagen nicht nachgelassen
gleichzeitig kündigt wladimir putin an
im herbst am gipfel der wichtigsten
industrie- und schwellenländer g-20
teilnehmen zu wollen sowieso soll in
moskau alles so laufen wie immer auch
der neunte mai der tag des sieges über
nazi deutschland
der tag wird mit viel militär gefeiert
die proben dazu laufen und christian
senn hat sie gesehen wenn panzer und
raketenwerfer im frühjahr durch moskaus
innenstadt rollen weiß jeder hier bald
ist wieder neunter mal probe gestern
abend während in der ukraine die
militärische spezialoperation läuft wie
der krieg hier offiziell bezeichnet wird
öffentlich kritisieren was gerade in der
ukraine passiert traut sich hier niemand
ich will das nicht kommentieren
ist nur fürs deutsche fernsehen
ohne kamera werde ich antworten
ich mag unseren präsidenten sehr denn er
beschützt uns ich möchte niemanden
kränken aber putin ist ein präsident für
die welt ich liebe ihn
jedes jahr wird mit der parade auf dem
roten platz an das ende des zweiten
weltkriegs erinnert dieses mal mit
weniger soldaten rund 11.000 und weniger
technik als im letzten jahr die
feierlichkeiten zum sieg über nazi
deutschland erscheinen in diesem jahr in
einem besonderen licht der kreml spricht
von bedeutenden verlusten bei der
militäroperationen in der ukraine und
präsident putin will hier am 9 mai
militärische erfolge präsentieren am
alten arbeit im touristenviertel werden
t shirts mit dem großen z verkauft
merchandising für die militäroperationen
und von der iss grüßen die russischen
kosmonauten zum neunten mai mit der
sowjetischen sieges flagge
es gibt wieder ein ganz frisches
zdf-politbarometer matthias fornoff ist
bei uns mit sehr vielen zahlen matthias
gestern hat der bundestag mit großer
mehrheit für die lieferung auch schwerer
waffen an die ukraine gestimmt wie
denken die bürger darüber ja guten abend
erstmal das hatte einen deutlichen
meinungsumschwung gegeben eine mehrheit
von 56 prozent ist jetzt dafür dass
deutschland auch schwere waffen an die
ukraine liefert im märz sah das noch
ganz anders aus 63 prozent lehnten das
ab wie die bundesregierung die ukraine
insgesamt unterstützt findet die hälfte
der befragten gerade richtig und fast
jeder dritte sagt das ist noch zu wenig
und wie machen politikerinnen und
politiker ihre sache in der ukraine
krise kanzler scholz stürzt da auf 49
prozent zustimmung ab im märz waren es
noch 72 prozent zwei drittel sagen
wirtschaftsminister habeck macht einen
guten job sogar 70 prozent attestieren
dass außenministerin berbalk die grünen
als partei legen denn auch zu im
politbarometer matthias nächsten sonntag
8 mai da gibt es landtagswahlen in
schleswig holstein wie sieht es da aus
der bundes- und landestrend die gehen
nicht immer in die gleiche richtung das
sehen wir hier denn wenn am sonntag
gewählt würde in schleswig-holstein
werke die cdu mit 38 prozent sehr klar
vorn spd 19 grüne 17 fdp 7 afd 6 linke 3
und südschleswigscher wählerverband 5
prozent das jamaika bündnis in kiel ist
im grunde beliebt es könnte aber auch
für ein zweierbündnis reichen ein grund
für die stärke der cdu ist sicher ihr
spitzenkandidat denn 66 prozent wollen
daniel günther als ministerpräsidenten
behalten die herausforderer weit
abgeschlagen da ist jedenfalls im moment
keine wechselstimmung festzustellen ja
dann vielen dank matthias fornoff war ja
nur ein kleiner vorgeschmack
das ausführliche politbarometer das gibt
es wie immer im heute-journal ab 22 uhr
und schon jetzt finden sie alle zahlen
in unserer zdf heute app auch zur
wirtschaftslage und der allgemeinen
politischen stimmung im land
die abhängigkeit von russischer energie
gilt nicht nur für importe sondern auch
für einige anlagen in deutschland die
mehrheitlich in besitz eines russischen
staatsunternehmens sind darum will die
bundesregierung der gesetzesnovelle die
möglichkeit bekommen zur not auch
unternehmen enteignen zu können bernd
benthin mit den einzelheiten die pck
raffinerie im brandenburgischen schwedt
versorgt große teile deutschlands mit
kraftstoffen und gehört zum größten teil
dem russischen rosneft-konzern für die
neue deutsche energiepolitik ein
unhaltbarer zustand erklärt der
wirtschaftsminister auf twitter posten
ist ein russischer staatskonzern und die
haben natürlich gar keine interessen
daran dass sie nicht russisches öl
raffinieren also wenn ich da anrufe und
sagt hallo was wollt ihr eigentlich tun
um unabhängig zu werden dann können die
hörer gar nicht ab und sagen hey was
willst du eigentlich von uns das ist
genau unser geschäftsmodell habeck seit
heute in corona isolation hofft dass er
bald härter gegen rosneft vorgehen kann
dafür wollen die ampel parteien das
energie sicherungs gesetz verschärfen
dann sollen auch enteignungen möglich
sein
jeder der kritische infrastruktur in
deutschland gegen die deutschen und
europäischen interessen missbraucht der
kann nicht weiter eigentümer dieser
kritischen infrastruktur sein meine
damen und herren auch die eigentümer von
gasspeichern sollen als letztes mittel
enteignet werden können einige dieser
russischen anlagen in deutschland stehen
schon jetzt unter treuhandverwaltung die
union signalisiert zustimmung zum neuen
gesetz die linke fordert man solle noch
weiter gehen wir als linke sagen
kritische infrastruktur gehört dauerhaft
in die öffentliche hand und das ist
glaube ich die richtige und wichtige
forderung in die st dort seien im mai so
jedenfalls der ampel plan soll das neue
gesetz beschlossen sein
jetzt nach afghanistan bei einer
schweren explosion in der hauptstadt
kabul sollen laut innenministerium
mindestens zehn menschen getötet worden
sein die bombe sei während des gebets in
einer moschee detoniert das land wird
seit wochen von anschlägen erschüttert
erst gestern wurden in masar i scharif
neun menschen durch explosionen in den
tod gerissen zu der tat bekannt hat sich
ein ableger des islamischen staates
der chef der europäischen
grenzschutzagentur frontex fabrice adde
jerry ist zurückgetreten hintergrund
sind so genannte push becks also die
illegale teils gewaltsame zurückweisung
von migranten im fokus der vorwürfe auch
immer wieder der griechische grenzschutz
berichten zufolge sollen führungskräfte
von frontex verstöße absichtlich
vertuscht haben frontex einheiten
unterstützen eu staaten an ihren
außengrenzen
zu corona da zeichnen sich weitere
lockerungen in deutschland ab wer
infiziert ist soll sich nur noch fünf
tage isolieren und nicht mehr wie bisher
in den meisten bundesländern zehn tage
darauf haben sich bund und länder
grundsätzlich geeinigt strittig ist
allerdings noch ob am ende ein test
freiwillig oder verpflichtend sein soll
britta spiekermann
lauterbach lockert bund und länder sind
sich einig und planen die
vorgeschriebene isolation für corona
infizierte von jetzt zehn auf fünf tage
zu verkürzen
ich persönlich glaube dass am ende rund
fünf tagen dass er sehr kurze zeit eine
selbsttötung zumindest eine
selbstrettung dringend empfohlen sein
müsste weil wir wissen dass viele nach
dem fünften tag noch positiv sind und
die würden dann ja doch noch andere
anstecken daher ist eine
freisetzung auch für diejenigen die
keine symptome mehr sinnvoll ein test
nach fünf tagen wird also vom minister
dringend empfohlen eine pflicht gibt es
nicht der virologe martin stürmer hält
das für nicht ausreichend zudem werde
die omikron variante verharmlost wenn
man aber alle spruch hat infektion zu
vermeiden dann kann man nicht einfach am
mikro so behandeln infektionen einfach
laufen lassen wir haben immer noch
ungeklärte situation als longo wird
angeht ärztevertreter hingegen
unterstützen lockerungen sie fordern
schon länger mehr eigenverantwortung
isolationen könnten angesichts hoher
infektionszahlen ohnehin kaum
kontrolliert werden zum einen haben wir
ja eine extrem hohe dunkelziffer das
heißt es ist ja eine scheinsicherheit zu
meinen mit diesen isolations pflichten
würde man relevant eingriff auf
inspektions geschehen nehmen und die
unter dem strich doch sehr milden
verlauf von omikron rechtfertigen dass
auch für medizinisches personal sollen
nach ende der fünftägigen isolation ein
test allerdings verpflichtend sein die
neuen empfehlungen wird das
robert-koch-institut kommende woche
veröffentlichen die umsetzung ist dann
ländersache
sie haben es mitbekommen krone bedingt
viel das münchner oktoberfest ja zwei
jahre hintereinander aus aber dieses
jahr wird wieder ozapft entschied jetzt
oberbürgermeister reiter statt einer
kleinen wiesen wie zurzeit gibt es ab
mitte september wieder die große wiesen
ganz ohne auflagen in münchen ist die
freude groß und sechs millionen besucher
lockte das größte volksfest der welt vor
der pandemie an
boris becker erfolgreichste
tennisspieler der deutschen geschichte
hat eine ganze generation begeistert
inspiriert und auch zum tennisspielen
gebracht jetzt ist die ikone zu
zweieinhalb jahren haft verurteilt
worden wegen insolvenzverschleppung
das gericht in england sprach ihn in
vier von 24 anklagepunkten schuldig nach
dem ersten wimbledonsieg 1985 kamen
millionen durch preisgeld und werbung
und gingen schnell verloren durch seinen
lebensstil ein unglückliches händchen
bei geschäften und teuren scheidungen
yasin herrlein aus london
es war genau 15 uhr 45 ortszeit als die
richterin das das verkündete zwei jahre
sechs monate haft davon maximal zwölf
monate auf bewährung am vormittag bei
der ankunft am gericht mit seiner
freundin war da vielleicht noch ein
hauch von zuversicht in beckers gesicht
über den nachmittag dann konnte er das
gerichtsgebäude nicht mehr durch den
haupteingang verlassen wie konnte es
dazu kommen für das tennis wunderkind
bis heute ist becker der jüngste
wimbledon sieger seither gehört er zu
den ikonen des deutschen sports er
machte millionen mit seinem tennis und
als werbefigur geld kam rein und gegen
noch schneller ein luxuriöser lebensstil
teure scheidung unterhalt für die
tochter aus der besenkammer-affäre kein
glück als unternehmer
2017 wird becker für bankrott erklärt
geschätzt 60 millionen euro schulden
doch becker kooperiert nicht ausreichend
im insolvenzverfahren das kommt zum
prozess sein anwalt argumentiert seine
berater seien schuld gewesen becker sei
zu jung zu berühmt geworden schon immer
gefordert im umgang mit geld doch
ungewissheit und unfähigkeit schützen
nicht vor strafe zur brillant becker auf
dem platz war so tiefen und sein fall am
17 juli 1985 geht er mit dem
wimbledon-triumph in die
geschichtsbücher ein fast vier
jahrzehnte später ist es wieder london
diesmal geht es ins gefängnis eine
berufung ist möglich die aussicht auf
erfolg eher zweifelhaft wortlos und
sichtlich geschockt verließen freundin
lilian und so nur das gerichtsgebäude
becker selbst wurde in einem
gefängniswagen weg gebracht
ein schwerer tag für bäckerfamilie und
bäcker freunde aber auch für die vielen
becker fans christina aber sportlich
bleibt er ein ganz ganz großer ist
unbestritten wir machen jetzt einen
schnitt zum fußball hin es geht um den
neuen trainer von österreichs nationen
und der kommt aus deutschland ralf
rangnick empfindet es als eine ehre
neuer teamchef der österreicher zu
werden zunächst für zwei jahre
erste herausforderungen bereits am
dritten juni nations league auswärts in
kroatien genug erfahrung hat er ja ein
paar monate übergangstrainer bei
manchester united liegen hinter ihm ein
schwieriges starensemble um cristiano
ronaldo hat er gekauft nun reizt die
neue aufgabe als nationaltrainer mit
großer vorfreude erfüllt mich
insbesondere die aussicht mit einer
jungen erfolgshungrigen mannschaft die
europameisterschaft in deutschland zu
bestreiten österreich erfahren ist
rangnick nach acht jahren als
sportdirektor in salzburg
er löst franco foda ab der die
wm-qualifikation verpasste trotz des
frühen ausscheidens in der champions
league soll rang nicht beratend tätig
bleiben für manchester hoffentlich muss
er in seinem neuen job weniger oft den
kopf schütteln
das deutsche finalduell frankfurt gegen
leipzig ist in der europa league
weiterhin gut möglich r b setzte sich im
halbfinal hinspiel gegen die glasgow
rangers mit 1 0 durch wobei an re linie
erst in der 85 minute den siegtreffer
erzielte und
großer jubel auch bei der eintracht die
im londoner hexenkessel von west ham
united flott los legte zwischendurch
etwas bangen musste und letztlich doch
mit 2 1 gewann die 3000 mitgereisten
frankfurter fans sorgten fast schon für
finalstimmung im londoner olympiastadion
die mannschaft schien dadurch beflügelt
bereits nach 49 sekunden die führung für
die eintracht durch drauf west ham nun
wachgerüttelt noch in der ersten
halbzeit antonio mit dem ausgleich nach
dem seitenwechsel die gäste aus
frankfurt wieder stärker kanada und das
erlösende 2 1 für frankfurt in der
nachspielzeit noch eine spektakuläre
szene fallrückzieher bauen und frankfurt
im glück das gehört der noch dazu das
muss man sich dann noch arbeiten von
daher war es eine sehr gute vorstellung
von uns schon mit einem unentschieden
nächste woche könnte der traum vom
endspiel in sevilla war
das wäre am 18 mal gucken das spiel habe
ich verpasst so geküsst so das
wochenendwetter zweigeteilt im norden
kühler und sonniger im süden viel
wechselhafter mehr gleich von katja
horneffer das heute journal heute um 22
uhr mit bettina schausten so viel von
uns vielen dank schön start ins
wochenende morgen hier für sie barbara
halben
[Musik]
guten abend heute war das wetter ja noch
vergleichsweise ruhig für viele schien
auch die sonne und es gab meist nur hohe
und harmlose wolkenfelder das wird sich
jetzt aber ändern denn hier von
frankreich kommen dichtere wolken heran
mit schauern und gewittern und die
beschäftigen uns schon heute abend und
auch in der nacht im westen und dem
südwesten deutschlands gibt es also
schauer und gewitter nordöstlich der
elbe dagegen bleibt ist klar und die
temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 2 grad
und steigen morgen hier im osten auf 18
bis 20 grad meist liegen die werte bei
13 bis 17 grad kühler ist es dagegen
hier an der nordseeküste und auch am
alpenrand mit elf grad allerdings sind
diese elf grad ganz unterschiedlichen
gründen geschuldet denn an der
nordseeküste liegt das an dem wind aus
nordwestlichen richtungen am alpenrand
dagegen gehen diese 11 grad zurück auf
die kräftigen wolken die es da gibt auch
kräftige schauer und gewitter da werden
sie die sonne kaum zu gesicht bekommen
schauer und gewitter beschäftigen vor
allen dingen die südhälfte deutschlands
im norden ist es freundlicher da
wechseln sonne und wolken miteinander ab
und diese regenschauer und gewitter von
morgen ziehen dann am sonntag weiter
richtung südosten dann kann sich am
oberrhein an der mosel auch mal wieder
die sonne zeigen schönes wochenende